The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
W
WILLIAM GREEN: So
let's get started.
This is my last
lecture of the class,
and I want to thank you guys.
This has been a
really good class.
I really enjoyed the good
questions on the forum
especially.
So I don't know if
you guys enjoyed it,
but I liked it anyway.
So I wanted to give--
my lecture here is
going to be a wrap up
on the stochastic methods,
and then professor Swan's
going to give a
review on Wednesday.
It will be the last
lecture of this class.
And then the final is a
week from today, I think.
Morning?
Yeah, morning.
All right.
So as you did in the
homework and we talked about,
there is a lot of
multidimensional integrals
we'd like to be
able to evaluate.
And a lot of them
have this form that
is a probability
density time some f
that we're trying to evaluate.
That's the integrand.
And then I didn't draw in the
millions of integral symbols
around it.
But usually x is a very
high dimensional thing,
so you have to integrate
a lot of things.
And often we actually
don't really know p.
We know a waiting factor, w.
So I just drew three
of the integrals there,
but there might be 10 to
the 23rd integrals there.
So w is a lot easier for us
to deal with than anything
with all those integral signs.
So for example, the
Boltzmann distribution
is one of these things.
And also, just
recall back earlier,
we were talking about
models versus data.
The Bayesian analysis
of experiments
says that you take your
likelihood function,
the likelihood that
you would have observed
the data you did if
the parameters were
true for certain value, theta.
And then you multiply that
times the prior knowledge
of the parameter values, and
that gives you the weighting
factor really for any
integrals involving parameters,
because it's really giving you
the w of data given everything
you know.
Prior information, and you also
know the new data you measured.
And put them all together,
you get the weighting factor
for the parameters.
And so you can
evaluate all kinds
of multidimensional integrals
over all the parameters
in the problem.
So very often you
might do experiments
where you maybe have
four or five or six
adjustable parameters,
theta, some of which
you know something
about ahead of time,
and you want to put
them together this way.
And that should be a summary
of everything you know.
But it's sort of a
goofball summary,
because it's a multidimensional
function, right,
a function with a
lot of variables.
But now you know how to
do integrals of functions
with lots of variables.
So you can compute things
like some linear combination
of-- what's the expectation
value of some function
of those parameters.
So if f, f here was
a function of theta--
why is it bouncing?
OK.
I wonder why you guys are
always look like this.
All right.
So f of theta, of any function
you want, you can evaluate--
it's a function
of the parameters,
like prediction of what will
happen in some new experiment
that depends on the parameters.
You'd have it as f of
theta, and then you
could integrate
it over w of theta
to get the expected value of the
result of the new experiment.
And also actually
the distribution
you have to get that way.
Does this make any sense?
I see one person
thinks it makes sense.
OK.
So just because we did
Monte Carlo using Boltzmann,
which is a common
one to use, there's
other weighting factors.
I guess that's my comment.
And anytime you end
up something that
has some integrals
with weighting factors,
then you should think, oh, I
can use Metropolis Monte Carlo.
And also, anytime you have
experiments, a lot of times
you think of the, OK, I want to
get the best fit least squares
approach, which is
what you already knew
before I taught you anything.
But it's very important to
remember that you can also
write the actual
probability density,
the shape of the probability
density the parameters.
And that way you can
get all the correlations
between the
parameters and include
all the previous knowledge
of the parameters
and stuff like that.
So it's a very important thing
to remember from this course
is this Bayesian formula.
All right.
But Metropolis Monte Carlo,
as you saw in the homework,
is not always that easy.
So you need to choose the step
length in every dimension.
It's sort of the
factor you're going
to multiply times random numbers
to figure out how far to step
from one state to the next.
And it's not so obvious how to
choose that before you start
because you may
not know that much
about the shape of
the integrand, right?
Actually, even with the strength
of the p in the probability
distribution, you might
not be that sure about it.
And so if you accidentally
choose it too large,
what will happen is it
tries to take big steps away
from a probable state and ends
up at really improbable states,
and then most of the times it
won't accept that transition,
right?
Metropolis Monte Carlo will
just repeat the same state
over and over again.
So if you see you just
keep sitting there getting
the same value over and
over and over again,
then that's warning
you that you must have
chose your stepsize too large.
Alternatively, if you
choose it too small,
all your steps will be
accepted because you're not
moving anywhere.
So you're basically
staying at the same point
over and over again, except it's
slightly different, because you
took a little tiny step.
But that way you
won't necessarily
sample the whole range.
And you can see
that by plotting.
They say the distance from
the initial state position.
You initiated the Monte Carlo
Markov chain at some state.
And if you plot probability
distribution of density,
the distance from all the new
states to the original state,
and if that number
is super teeny tiny,
then you might be a little
concerned that you really
didn't cover the whole space.
But again, you have to know
what is super teeny tiny,
so you have to have
a range in mind.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Can you
do this adaptively?
WILLIAM GREEN: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So good algorithms for
this try to pick it up
that there's a
problem, like if it
keeps on either not
accepting any states,
it would try to shrink
the step, the delta.
Or if it's always
excepting the states,
then it might try
to increase it.
You want accept actually
most of the transitions
because it makes
it more efficient.
But you don't accept them all.
So you want to do some--
I don't know-- keep it to
0.9 probability or something
like that, or 0.8.
And there is probably
a whole journal paper
about what's the optimal way
to do the adaptive stepsizing
to get to convert the rest.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: How did you prevent
your initial guess [INAUDIBLE]??
WILLIAM GREEN:
Well, to me, I don't
think that throwing
them out is a good idea.
I don't know.
People do it.
I think it's that
your really just need
to make enough steps that
you are sampling everywhere,
and then it shouldn't matter.
And a good thing
to do is actually
start from a completely
different initial state
and make sure you get the
same value of the integral,
and that will give you
a lot more confidence
that you're not sensitive to it.
If you're sensitive to
it, you're in trouble.
Because you really won't
know how many to throw away.
And you don't know if you
actually even achieved
the real integral.
I think in the hydrogen
peroxide example,
actually it was symmetrical,
so it was a little bit
didn't matter too much.
But it I had given you
an asymmetrical one,
there's like--
here's like the dihedral angle.
It has to do with the
orientation of the h,
like sort of out of the plane.
And it should be
symmetrical that you
can sort of plus and
minus, and there's
a high probability
region over here
and a high probability
region over here.
And you start one of
them, say, over here,
and you just sample
around here, you
get a lot of points
all have basically
the same value dihedral angle.
And you never see any of these,
then it's no good, right?
Now this particular
case, you might still
get the right answer by
luck, because they're exactly
symmetrical.
If this one is a little
bit asymmetrical,
then you'd get the wrong answer.
Does that make sense?
So you really want to
make sure you're really
sampling over all the
physically accessible region.
But again, this is
a common problem
for us all the time,
is that when you're
doing a calculation,
you want to know what
the answer is before you start.
This is a absolutely
critical thing.
Because how the heck you going
to know if you have a bug?
Right?
The computer's going to give
you some number at the end.
You have to know actually what
the answer is before you start.
I know this seems weird, right?
But anyway, it's the truth.
If you're going to
calculate anything,
you really want to know
what the answer is roughly.
What the units are, what
the order of magnitude is.
Some things about it.
And ideally you should try to
think of some simple test you
can do to try to check
whether your code's right,
whether things are reasonable.
The reasonableness
test, is it reasonable
that what which you get.
So this is the
same kind of thing.
Like you draw the H2O2
and say, oh, I think
the dipole moment should
be about such and such,
because I know the typical
charges on an H atom and O
atom.
And if you get some number
that's way off from that,
then obviously you made a
mistake somewhere, right?
It could be a
mistake in your code,
or it could just be you
just didn't sample correctly
because your delta was
wrong, for example.
All right?
Now I know I've told this
to students every time,
and every time I tell
this to students,
they totally reject this idea
that you should know the answer
before you start.
But it's absolutely critical.
I mean, my whole
job as a professor
is I tell my students,
please calculate this.
But before I tell them that, I
know what the answer is, right,
roughly.
And so that way when they
come back and show it to me,
I can say, oh, it's
reasonable, OK, I believe them.
Yeah.
So I think the
number should be 20
and they come back with
14.3, I say, 20, 14.3,
they're pretty close.
OK, so I believe them.
And when I think
it's 20 and they
come back, it's 10 to the minus
6, then I'm pretty confident,
I tell them, I think you
must have made a mistake.
And they're like, no, no,
no, I did a great job.
I'm sure my calculus is perfect.
And then I'm like, now
we're really probing,
and I think I'm like--
I don't know--
I have it in for them.
But no, actually I knew
what the answer is,
so obviously it can't be right.
So they must have
made a mistake.
Anyway, you should
be like it, too.
You want to be able to be
self-critical about what
do you expect your answers
to be before you do them.
All right.
What else is problematic
with Monte Carlo?
This is very problematic.
If you want to
achieve high accuracy,
you need a really
large number of states.
And it's funny.
It's like you can get a pretty
good accuracy with not very
many samples because
of the behavior of one
over square root of n.
So it has very big changes,
that small values of n.
And just a relatively small
number of samples, you
get something that's
halfway reasonable.
But then if you have
three significant figures
and you want to
get the fourth one,
it's a killer because you have
to do 100 times more effort,
100 times more samples to get
one more significant figure.
And so you've
already done 100,000,
and now all the sudden you
have to do 10 million samples.
And then you only get one
more [INAUDIBLE] of that.
Now you have to do
a billion samples,
and it's like, this
gets really out of hand.
So that's a really
unfortunate thing about it.
But the nice behavior at the
beginning is you get roughly--
if you only want a few
significant figures,
you can get them pretty
darn fast with Monte Carlo,
certainly a lot
better than trying
to do the trapezoid rule in
multidimensions or something
like that.
All right.
So you guys just
did Monte Carlo.
Are there things I
should tell you about
or we should talk about,
problems you ran into?
Now you see, when I set that
homework problem up for you,
I helped you out a lot.
I don't know if
you noticed that.
So the original problem
had, it's four atoms,
they each have
three xyz positions.
So there's 12 coordinates.
And then I did clever
tricks to get it down to,
I think, six, maybe.
OK.
So going from six
dimensions to 12 dimensions,
that's actually a
pretty big deal.
And so if I have given you
the original 12-dimensional
problem, you could still
compute it and actually
use the same kind of
code as you wrote.
But the number samples you'd
need to get a good number
gets really wildly different.
Right, and so again, this
has to do with knowing
the answer ahead of time.
You know, I knew, OK, that the
magnitude of the dipole moment
doesn't depend on the
orientation of the molecule,
so therefore, I'm
going to get rid
of all the rotational
degrees of freedom.
I know it doesn't depend on
the transitional position
of the molecule, so therefore,
I get rid of all those.
And so before I even
did any calculation,
I can tell you I can get rid
of six degrees of freedom,
so that'll help you a lot.
But it's a similar
kind of thing.
You want to do that all the
time yourself, is try to think
what can I do that's easier
than just doing the brute force
problem?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So on that problem,
changing the max stepsize,
you could change the percentage
of step-- or [INAUDIBLE]..
WILLIAM GREEN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And I think the mean
state roughly around the same,
but the shape of distribution
actually changed a little bit.
WILLIAM GREEN: OK.
AUDIENCE: So how is--
WILLIAM GREEN: So I think it
might be this kind of thing
is one part of it.
It's like if you only integrate
one lobe of the dihedral,
you actually get a dipole
moment value that's
pretty reasonable, even if you
totally missed this other lobe.
But if you did a
different stepsize,
you might start getting
some samples over here, too.
So the distribution would
look a lot different,
but you still end up
getting roughly the mean.
But also it's partly that the--
the good thing about
the Monte Carlo method
is that, the first few samples,
no matter what they are,
give you something that's on
the order of magnitude of what
the value of the thing is.
So even a really lousy
sampling at the beginning
still gives you
something that's halfway
reasonable for the average.
AUDIENCE: So if you're
trying to recreate
the overall
distribution histogram,
then how do you know which max
stepsize to choose, because
[INAUDIBLE].
WILLIAM GREEN: Yeah, so the
rule of thumb I've heard
is that people try
to get an acceptance
ratio between 0.2 and 0.8.
So it means you want--
Yeah.
But I really don't know.
I'm not an expert in this field.
But I'm sure you read
papers and people have
big discussions about what
the acceptance ratio should
be in order to taking
big enough steps
that you have a chance
to get the weird stuff.
In this kind of one,
it might be a problem
if you're doing steps,
say, in the dihedral,
you may have to step
quite a long distance
to find the other lobe.
So sometimes having
some pre-knowledge
of what you think the shape of
the things are is a big help.
Yeah?
No?
Sorry, maybe I didn't
answer your question.
Is that--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
WILLIAM GREEN: Yeah.
All right.
All right, so
that's Monte Carlo.
To Then we talked about
the more difficult problem
of where the probability
distribution is not stationary,
and in fact, we don't even
have the w written out.
All we have is a
differential equation
that divides the
probability distribution.
And we did it here for the
case of discrete states,
and that's the right
one to use, for example,
for the kinetics
equation, if you
want to get them exactly right.
Now that differential equation
looks really easy, right?
Just a the times p.
It's a linear differential
equation system.
You knew how to do
that one probably
in your second semester
of undergraduate
taking differential
equations class, right?
They did dialyze the matrix.
Yeah?
Remember this?
So that looks really simple.
But the problem is that the
number of states is so big.
So have any of you tried problem
two on the optional homework?
You haven't tried?
Has anyone even looked at it?
I know somebody
looked at it because I
got some question about it.
All right.
At least one person
looked at it.
Let me tell you guys briefly
what this problem is.
It's a really relevant problem.
If you go work for Professor
Jensen, Professor Braatz, maybe
Professor Roman, you might
ed up doing this calculation.
This is not a crazy calculation.
It's very simple.
All they have is like
a chess board of sites
on a catalytic surface.
And they some number of sites.
And this is what-- if you
take a crystalline catalyst
and cleave it, you'll have
a whole repetitive pattern
on the surface, and
somewhere along there
is some active site
that does something.
You can tell that
experimentally because you
stick that catalyst in the
presence of some gases,
you make products
that you didn't
make when it wasn't there.
So it did something.
So the way people
model this is they
say, OK, there's some
active sites on here,
and there's probably one of
them per unit cell maybe.
And the site can
either be empty,
like if I ultra high vacuum,
I pump on it and heat it,
should be nothing there.
And then if I expose it to
a little bit of some gas A,
some of the sites might have A
molecules sticking on them now.
And I also exposed to some sites
gas B. Maybe one of these sites
might have a B
molecule on it, too.
And if A and B can react
and make my product,
C, then maybe they're
sitting next to each other
and they might react
with each other.
OK, so this is the whole way
you look at this problem.
And so all I want to know is, if
I have some A's and B's sitting
on the surface, sort of how
often are they going to react?
And the problem is a little
bit more complicated.
It says, well,
suppose I also know
if I put a whole lot of B on the
surface, what I end up seeing
is coke.
My whole surface gets
totally coked up.
So let's model that
by saying, well,
if suppose two B's are next to
each other, then some probably
reacting to turn to
some coke product that
sticks there permanently and
just poisons the catalyst.
OK?
And this is real
life, too, right?
So if you're trying to
run a catalytic process,
a lot of times, you have
to run with one reagent
in great excess to keep
the surface kind of clean,
keep it covered by the
unharmful reactant.
And then you let little
bits of the other reactant
come down and react with
the A really quickly.
But you don't let too much of
the second reactant come down,
because it might cause a
problem like dimerize or coke
or something.
OK, so that's the model.
Some of these guys have
A's, some of them have B's.
And in the unlikely case
that two of these guys react,
they both turn around and
then turn them into S's.
Coke.
Soot.
And then that part's
dead forever after that.
OK, so that's the model.
So in the case that they
have, they had 100 sites.
I think it was 10 by 10
if I remember correctly.
So it's 100 sites, and
each site can either
be empty, or have an A
molecule, or have a B molecule,
or have a coke
molecule, S. So there's
four different states on
each of 100 different sites.
So how many states
are there altogether?
Its' four to the what?
100.
OK.
So that's a pretty big number.
So that's how many states.
It's about 10 to
the 60th, I think.
All right.
So this is a very large number.
This is bigger than
Avogadro's number.
This is really a lot of states.
You wouldn't have thought that
just a stupid little problem
with just a 10 by 10
piece of catalyst,
and three different things
that can stick there,
would give you so many
numbers, but it does.
So now I have a problem
that if I have--
my p vector is now
a probability that
has a number for each of the
10 to the 60th possible states.
And then the matrix m is
that number squared, right?
Dimension.
So it's 10 to the 120th power
elements inside the matrix m.
So even though the
matrix m is very sparse,
this might still be a problem,
because 10 to the 120th
is really big, OK?
And your computer can only
hold 10 to the 9th or 10
to the 10th numbers in it, so
this is going to be a problem.
And also that's
not just what p is.
That's what p is
at this instant,
say, 1 millisecond
after t naught.
And then if I wait to 1.1
milliseconds after t naught,
p will be different.
So I have 10 to the 60th
numbers that change with time
in some way that I don't know.
OK?
So this is actually a really
hard problem to solve it.
And so everybody uses
Kinetic Monte Carlo to do it,
because there's no way
I can possibly even list
all the elements of p.
And in fact, if I sample, if
there's 10 to 60th states,
no matter how good my
sampling algorithm is,
I'm never going to sample
10 to the 60th states.
So there's a lot of states I'm
never going to get-- not even
get one sample of.
I'm just never going
to encounter them
at all, because there's
just too many states.
But anyway, people do it anyway.
So we go ahead and we'll
do the Gillespie algorithm,
which you guys--
we talked about in class.
Now to compute a
Gillespie trajectory,
we have to compute two
random numbers, right?
We compute one random
number, it tells us
how long we wait until
the next thing happens.
And then we compute a
second random number
that tells us which of the
many possible things that
happened actually happened.
And so if I have a
case like this where I
had the-- to the original case.
What can happen, the A
could react with the B,
the B could react to the B.
The A could come back off.
The A can move to the
next adjacent site.
The B can move to the
A lot of things
can happen, right?
So quite a variety of things can
happen from this initial state.
And so you have to, if
you're solving this problem,
you have to write that down.
Yeah, John Paul?
AUDIENCE: So the
special waiting times
are [INAUDIBLE] process
where we haven't decided
there's going to be an
arrival, [INAUDIBLE] arrival
times by that [INAUDIBLE].
WILLIAM GREEN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And then we
make something happen.
But I mean I feel like you could
run the exact same simulation
without counting the times.
Get the same answer and
then after the fact come
and [INAUDIBLE] into the system.
[INAUDIBLE] doesn't
seem to be [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM GREEN:
Yes, that's right.
Yeah, that's true.
So you only do the
time calculation
because you care about the time.
If you don't care
about the time,
you only care about the
steady-state solution,
then you can probably
do it some other way.
AUDIENCE: You don't
need to calculate
the times inside that.
You could calculate the
entire state space trajectory
without any reference
to the time, yeah?
WILLIAM GREEN: Yes.
Yeah, so you can
get the sequence
of all things that happened
if it didn't give you
the time, because it
doesn't matter, right?
For the time.
It just means the
sequence of what happened.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
WILLIAM GREEN: The sequence
of states is all that matters.
But if you want the
kinetic information,
then you also want
the time, because it
might be it sat in one
state for a million years,
and the other state--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM GREEN: Yeah.
Yeah, that's right.
Let's go ahead.
OK, so maybe make this cheaper.
Make it one random number for j.
No?
OK.
All right.
So things to just keep
in mind about this.
So the cost here is to
compute in random numbers.
We have to compute at least--
well, some number
of random numbers.
I don't know how many.
And that number depends
on the length of time
I want to simulate and
what my delta t is.
Where the delta t is sort
of like the average time
between the events happening.
It's like one over a
in the [INAUDIBLE]..
And so if that delta
t is very small,
and my time I want to
simulate is very large,
that means that
each trajectory is
going to have a lot of events.
And that means I'm going
to have to generate
a lot of random numbers.
And so generate
one trajectory is
going to be really expensive.
On the other hand, if the delta
t were about the same size
as the total time
I'm simulating,
then I might only get
one or two events,
and so I only have to
generate four random numbers
for each sample.
All right?
And I just have to
keep in mind that I'm
going to have a lot of
low probability states
that I'm not going
to sample at all.
I might even have
some high probability
states I don't sample, because
I just can't do enough samples.
And I had the same exact problem
I have with the Metropolis
Monte Carlo and with all
these stochastic methods
that the scaling is one
over square root of n.
So I can get a rough
idea pretty easily,
but I don't get a really
precise number of anything,
then I'm going to have
a problem because I'm
going to have trouble to do
enough samples to really refine
the number.
The key thing in this
is that with anything
like this where I'm going
to have so many states,
I'm going to run a
lot of trajectories
to get at all-- sample all
the things that can happen.
And so I'm probably
not going to be
able to store all
the trajectories
I ran on my computer, because
I'm going to run so many.
And so I really want
to compute things
on the fly, which means I
should decide ahead of time
all the averages, all the
f's I'm trying to compute.
So I might only compute
f and f squared.
And I don't know, whatever
else I want to compute.
The average value of the
number of A's on the surface.
I mean, there might be a lot
of diagnostics I can compute
to just check everything's OK.
Think of that beforehand,
coded to compute them
as it runs, and then we only
have to store the running
averages of all
those quantities,
and I don't have to store
anything about exactly which
state sequence I hit.
Is that OK?
All right.
Now if you remember,
in this equation,
there was an initial condition
of the right-hand side, which
we totally ignored so far.
But that's actually
pretty important.
And in a lot of real cases,
from your macroscopic continuum
view of things, you have an idea
of the average value events.
And what you don't know
is about the discreteness
and you don't know
about the correlations.
All you know is
sort of an average.
I expect to have two A's
and three B's in the surface
or something from the
partial pressure of A and B
and the binding constants of
A and B. So I have some idea.
So I think I know
these averages.
And so what people usually do is
they use a Poisson distribution
for the probability of
the exact number of A.
So I suppose I think on average
I'll have two A's. , Well,
I might have one A, I might
have three A's on the surface.
And so I'll just use the
Poisson distribution of n
to get an estimate of
sort of the expected
width of distributions.
And so that's the formula
for the Poisson distribution.
You have to know the average
values of Na, Nb, Nc.
And then you can see that
the N appears in the--
on average, N appears
in the exponent
and in the factorial
[INAUDIBLE]..
Right?
And so really every
time you start
a new trajectory in Kinetic
Monte Carlo, what you should do
is sample from the
Poisson distribution
to get a new initial
condition as well.
OK?
And that way you're
sampling over both
all the possible initial
conditions and all
the possible things
that can happen
to them to really get the real
average of what you might want.
All right.
Now we just realized how
horrible this problem is
because it has so many states.
And so then we're going to
have to think immediately,
what can I do to make
this faster and easier?
And so here are some
things people do.
One thing is that
people try to figure out
what are the really
fast processes,
and do I care about them.
And some of the fast
processes, you might say, well,
like diffusion of
A moving to here,
and then it moves to here, and
then it moves back to here,
then it moves back to here.
That's of no interest to me.
I don't care where the A
is bound on the surface.
All right?
The only way I care about it
is whether the reacts of the B
when it's sitting next to it.
In other respects, I really
don't care about the diffusion.
So having the time
concept for the diffusion
be the real time concept
might not be that important.
So then you can do
different things.
One thing is you can assume
it's infinitely fast,
and you say, well, every
time I look at a site,
I assume that this A has a 1/10
chance of being here or here
or here or here or here,
all these different spots,
as if it's equilibrated
around all the empty sites.
That would be one
possible way to do it.
That's the infinitely
fast diffusion idea.
Another idea is to say,
well, let's slow down
the fusion to make
it slower just
to help out our computation.
So I say, well, on
average, I might
get one reaction a millisecond.
In reality, the diffusion
time is a nanosecond.
But I don't care about
all that nanosecond stuff.
Let's pretend that it's
a tenth of a millisecond.
So it'll still be
pretty much equilibrated
on the time scale
on the reactions,
but that way I'll be able
to accelerate my calculation
by seven orders of magnitude
by going from a nanosecond time
scale to a tenth of a
millisecond time scale.
So there's a lot of
different tricks like that.
If you read a paper that
does Kinetic Monte Carlo,
you've got to read
exactly what they did.
But they usually do
something like this,
because it's just
totally out of hand
if you try to model
everything perfectly.
Also, the low
probability events,
the really low
you're never going to sample.
So if I have a process that
happens on my catalyst that
takes 10 hours to happen,
and my main reaction
happens on a
millisecond time scale,
I'm never going to be able
to run out to 10 hours.
So I might as well
just forget it.
So if I know experimentally
that the coking thing only
happens on 10-hour time scale,
I'd just take it out of there.
And I don't have to clutter up
my calculation with all these
S's.
I'm not going to form any of
them in my time scale anyway.
And so therefore, I cut
the number of states.
Instead of being 4 to the
100th, now it's 3 to the 100th
because I got rid
of all the coke.
And so now I've drastically
reduced the size of my problem.
Not often you can do
a reduction like this.
That's a pretty big reduction
in the size of a problem.
All right?
And then you have
to have an idea
of what adequate sampling is.
So you're going to see
some lower probability
processes compared to some
higher probability ones.
And you have to know,
when are these low ones so
small that they're
statistical noise.
And this is the margin
of error problem.
Do you ever see the polling,
like in the political polls,
they always say, so-and-so many
people believe in evolution
plus or minus something, right?
Well, the way they
get the plus or minus
is from the square root
of the number of samples
with a positive
result. So the margin
of error on low probability
things is much larger.
So the number of people who
believe that Professor Greene
is God is a very small number.
So if you find
somebody like that,
you have to figure they're
within the margin of error,
right?
OK?
But the number of people
who are going to attend 1034
this morning is a
big enough number
that the margin of error in that
is maybe two or three people.
It's not going to be 100 people.
That make sense?
All right.
So the more likely the
event is, the more likely
you'll get a lot
of samples of it
if you count the errors roughly
the square root of the number
of samples you
got of that event,
then the statistical
error in your sample
of the high probability
events won't be that large.
Whereas for the low
probability events,
it could be really gigantic.
All right, so just
for an example.
In the main reaction,
A plus B is really fast
because it's a good catalyst.
So I'm going to get
a lot of trajectories
going to show that reaction.
So that's good.
And I should get good
samples [INAUDIBLE]
But the coking reaction
is really slow.
At least I hope
it's slow, otherwise
the catalyst is no good.
And so if it's really
slow, I might not
get very many of those guys.
And so even if I left
it in the calculation,
I might not be able to reach any
conclusion because I might only
see one when coking even
out of all of the 100,000
trajectories I run.
And so then I won't know
whether to say anything
about that or not.
And then if I let the
diffusion in and it's too fast,
then my delta t
is going to be too
large, which means
that my CPU time
to compute a single trajectory
is going to be too large,
which means that I won't be able
to get good sampling because I
won't be able to run
very many trajectories.
So I might want to do
something to get rid of that.
All right.
Now there's another method
that a lot of people use.
I think actually Professor
Swan uses this sometimes.
Is that correct?
Yes.
So this is another method.
And what it is, is you
solve the equations
of motion of the atoms or
clumps of atoms typically using
Newton's equations of motion.
And typically people use
it using force fields that
were fitted to some
experimental data,
and maybe with some
quantum chemistry data
as well, to get some idea of
the forces between the atoms
and the force with
which the molecules,
when they bump into each
other, how they interact.
And typically, it's
done classically
using Newton's
equations of motions.
But if you don't
like that, you can
put in the quantum
mechanical effects
in a couple of different
ways, and my groups,
worked them one way called RPMD.
And you can get
pretty good agreement
with the quantum
chemical results
by doing this fancier version
of molecular dynamics.
So there's some
different equations
you solve, but
basically the same.
And so you can do it.
And there's a nice
algorithm called
the velocity of Verlet algorithm
that almost everybody uses
in this field.
And what's nice
about that one is
that it can do a lot of steps.
A lot of steps of
moving the atoms around.
And after you do a
million steps like that,
you compute the
energy by adding up
all the potential
energies and kinetic
energies of all the atoms.
And it'll still be
about the same energy
as you started from.
Whereas a lot of methods, if
you do the integral like that
and you calculate the
energy at the end,
it won't be the same as
energy you calculated
because the methods have
little round-off errors,
and they kind of accumulate in
a way that messes up the energy.
And so this particular
algorithm is
a nice O to E solver
method that is good for--
has a property that is good
for conserving the energy.
And then a lot of
people use a thermostat,
because they care
about samples that are
in contact with a thermal bath.
So you're sampling a few
molecules, maybe 100 molecules
or 1,000 molecules, but not
10 to the 23rd molecules.
So you have your 100 molecules
or your 1,000 molecules,
and you pretend that they're
in contact with some bath,
and you're watching those
100 molecules wiggle around,
and their energy is
not exactly conserved
because they're exchanging
energy with a thermal bath.
And so there's different
things called thermostats
which are computer
ways of adjusting
the velocities of the
atoms periodically
as if they got a kick
from the thermal bath that
makes them go up or down.
And that's very important trying
to do, say, chemical kinetics,
because their reactions are
so slow that most of the time
you'll watch the atoms wiggling
around, nothing happens.
You need the unusual case when
you get a big kick somewhere
that gives you enough energy
that you overcome a barrier
to make a reaction happen.
All right.
So that's what
molecular dynamics is.
And numerous people in the
world and in this department
and on the campus do these
kind of calculations.
And there's two ways
that they're used.
One way is used
as an alternative
to Metropolis Monte Carlo.
So you're trying to compute
basically multidimensional
integrals, basically it's
from statistical mechanics
integrals, more or less.
And instead of using
Metropolis Monte Carlo,
you decide to use
molecular dynamics.
This is a tricky choice
between those two options.
Nice thing about the
molecular dynamics
is I didn't have to choose any
stepsize, basically, right?
it's like the time scale was
set by the real physical motions
of the atoms.
And if I don't want
to think about it,
I can just put in, what's
the real physical time scale
of the vibration of some atoms.
And I don't have to think about
it at all and just run it.
But something should be a
little bit thinking about
is the molecular dynamics
equations we're solving,
it's really a time
accurate method.
We actually get real
time dependences.
We're using the real physical
time, which turns out
to be pretty darn fast.
So molecular vibrations
or time scales
are like tens of femtoseconds.
And so that's really fast.
And so you have a
really tiny delta t.
But if you're trying to
actually compute a steady state
property, then maybe this
isn't-- it's not necessarily
the best way to do it, OK?
Because you're doing something
where you're doing extra effort
to keep the time accuracy.
It's sort of along the lines
of John Paul's question.
If you're doing Kinetic Monte
Carlo, if you didn't really
care about the time, then you
don't have spend time computing
the time, right?
And the same thing here
is if you don't really
care about the
time, then you might
want to use the Metropolis
Monte Carlo instead,
because if time's not
really in your problem,
then you can tailor it,
take steps that don't really
have to be physical or related
to physical amounts of time,
and you can still get
the right integral.
Whereas here, it's
going to necessarily do
things that are exactly the
physical amount of time.
And some processes
in the real world
are pretty darn slow, at least
compared to 100 femtoseconds.
So you might have
problems trying to compute
by a time accurate method.
Now on the other
hand, sometimes you
want to compute time
dependent properties.
And this is more or
less an exact simulation
of what the molecules
really do on the time scale
that you're simulating.
So if that's what
you care about,
like what's happening on the
time scale of picoseconds
and nanoseconds, this
might be exactly right,
because you're actually
simulating with a tool that's
time accurate on the time
scale of what you're really
trying to measure.
And so some chemical reactions,
some kinds of energy transfer
processes, like
Professor Tisdale's group
has exciton transfers that are
happening on picosecond time
scales.
It's tailored to
that kind of problem.
OK, but this is the limitation.
So you have to use a
very small delta t.
Therefore, your total
time is typically
limited to nanoseconds as
far as you can integrate,
because you have to--
if you just count how many
time steps you would need.
So if you're trying to determine
some kind of static equilibrium
property, you start
from some initial gas
at the positions of the atoms
and the initial velocities,
and then physically, it
takes some time scale
for that initial gas to relax
to the real equilibrium,
because you don't know
the real equilibrium
situation of the system.
And that time scale, if it's
longer than nanoseconds,
you're in trouble,
because it's not
going to be done before
you've done the calculation.
And you never have even achieved
the equilibrium situation.
Also, if you have a situation
like that hydrogen peroxide
case we talked about,
suppose it takes
a millisecond for
the hydrogen peroxide
to change confirmation from the
dihedral angle being one way
and to be the other way.
If I can only say, well,
simulate for a nanosecond,
then I'm never going
to see that happen.
So I'm never going to jump from
the one conformer to the other.
On the other hand, if I care
what happens inside the one
conformer, everything
inside there
probably happens on
nanosecond time scales,
and so I'll get the
really good sampling
of what's happening
inside the one conformer.
And similarly for the
dynamic processes,
if you have a process that
happens on nanosecond time
scale, this is really
the ideal way to do it.
If you have a process that's
happening on millisecond
or seconds or hours
time scales, then
this is not really the
way to do it at all.
And then there's an initial
condition problem with this.
It's kind of related to
the Kinetic Monte Carlo
initial condition problem.
So in the Kinetic
Monte Carlo, we
had to sample over all the
possible initial conditions.
We did it with the
Poisson distribution.
There is a similar
issue here, is how do I
start the initial conditions?
Where do I arrange the
atoms to be to start out?
I really want to sample over
all the different possible ways
the molecules could be arranged.
And particularly
if I have some--
say I have a protein.
And the protein has some
conformation it likes to sit-in
and then it can unfold and go
to some other conformation.
Maybe there's two or three
conformations like this.
The time scales
for those changes,
again, might be milliseconds.
I'm not going to be
able to follow them
with the molecular
dynamic, so I need
to have some sampling
method to set me up
in each of the
different conformations
that I want to sample.
And then I can follow
very accurately
what would happen over
a couple nanoseconds
after it's in that confirmation.
But I'll hardly ever
see it actually achieve
the other confirmation
on the time scale.
So I guess what I
want to say to you
guys is these are
different tools for really
different purposes.
The Metropolis Monte Carlo,
the Kinetic Monte Carlo,
and the molecular
dynamics, they're
all good for some
kinds of problems.
But none of them is
good for all problems.
And I often get
journal papers where
somebody uses the wrong
method for the wrong problem.
And so I have to reject it.
I've often had people come that
want to do postdocs for me.
And they're talking
about their thesis,
and I see the poor kid has spent
five years of his life using
the wrong tool for the
problem he's doing.
It's very sad.
So don't that be you, OK?
So don't just use a tool
because you know it.
Say, does this tool
work for this problem?
If not, I've got
to find a new tool.
And just make sure you're using
tools that match the problems
you want that you're
trying to solve.
I think that's all I got.
So I have 10 more
minutes left in class.
Any questions you guys have?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Just have one
on weighting functions
for the Monte Carlo simulations.
I'm still a little shaky on
how you always determine them.
It seems like it was given
to us on the problem we
did on the homework and then
in the example in class,
you just set it to
an even distribution,
or a uniform distribution?
WILLIAM GREEN: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: How do you choose
what's best, how do you know
[INAUDIBLE]?
WILLIAM GREEN: Yeah.
Well, yes.
So you get some integral.
This integral of
g of x something.
All right?
Where this is a lot.
And then you have
to figure out, what
am I going to do so I
can solve this thing?
And the clever thing
is to figure out, hmm,
can I rewrite this as p of
x times f of x, because I
know how to solve those kind.
And actually, I don't even--
Yeah, and even if I don't
know what p is really,
maybe I can write it as w of x
over some number of integrals
here.
That will be my p of x.
So most of these things you can
do with uniform distributions
if you want.
But then your sampling can
be extremely inefficient,
because you'll sample
a lot of regions
that have very low probability
of being really there.
But this is like
a cleverness thing
about can I figure out
what's that p times f
that's equal to g that's
going to work the best for me.
And work the best,
that's a good question.
So one way of working the best
is, if f is most constant,
because if f is
perfectly constant,
then I get the right
answer in the first sample.
OK?
So that's one thing is
trying to figure out
f to be really pretty constant.
The second one is
to try to figure out
p that's very sharply focused.
So I don't need to sample a
lot of x values to get it.
Now these two are kind of
at odds with each other,
the sharp p and the flat f.
Probably again,
probably whole people
wrote their PhD thesis
in applied mathematics
about what's the optimal
choice of p and f.
A lot of times,
I'm not that smart,
so I just like, if I have a
problem in stat mech, I just--
I'll always do a
Boltzmann factor.
It may not really
the best thing to do,
but that's what I
would do, right?
And if I was doing
a Bayesian problem,
it's sort of like the w
is given to you, right?
Where's that?
That's the formula I know,
so I'm going to use that w.
Maybe there's a more
clever way to do it,
but that's what I
normally would do.
Actually, one thing that
I don't know if we've ever
talked about explicitly,
but very important to know,
is that this kind of formula,
these formulas have w of theta.
That's the joint probability
that theta one is something,
and theta two is something,
and theta three is something,
and theta four is something.
It's that probably density.
But a lot of times,
you don't care
about that level of detail.
Like you may have only a
few of those parameters
that matter to you.
So you really care, you
would like to know p of--
I don't know, theta
one, theta two.
And you'd like to get rid of
all the rest of the thetas,
because these are two thetas
you really care about.
Maybe these are
the ones you think
you're controlling
in your experiment,
you're trying to determine.
In the other ones,
somebody already
measured the mass of the
proton, so you really
don't want to determine
the mass of proton again,
and you're not going to
really say anything about it
even if you did.
If your calculation
says that it made
the mass of proton a little
bit different than what
the standard book says,
you might believe that
in your heart that it's true,
but you're probably not going
to say it, because you're
like, I better double
check before I do that.
But I'm sure that it determines
the length of my reactor,
because I measured that
with a meter stick,
and nobody else
knows that number,
so I'm sure that's the
theta I got that I'm really
going to be in control of here.
So oftentimes you do this.
You want theta one, theta
two, but you actually
know theta one, theta two,
theta three, quite a few of them
from my formula.
And so you can do what's
called a marginal integral.
Suppose I have-- I don't
know-- theta three, theta four.
I could do D theta
three, D theta four.
And this is like integrating
out these degrees of freedom
to get the probability density
that I want, all right?
So if you have some case where
you all you care about is
the variance of
something, and you
don't care about
all the rest, you
can kind of integrate them out.
That's a very handy trick to do.
Well, you can do similar things
with the Boltzmann things,
like for example, a lot of
the Boltzmann distributions,
we don't actually care
about the momenta,
because what we measure, say,
is like a crystallography thing.
We see positions of atoms.
We don't see velocities anyway.
So a lot of times,
people will just
integrate all the velocities
out of the problem
right at the beginning.
It depends on what
you want, right?
You're in charge
of your problem.
Any more questions?
Yes, Kristen.
AUDIENCE: OK, well, I
just have an announcement.
WILLIAM GREEN: OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
today at office hours,
we'll talk about KMC, probably
from about 5:00 to 5:30,
but come any other time
[INAUDIBLE] questions.
And we just posted a poll
for the final review session.
It's either going to be
Wednesday evening or Friday
morning, so if you could vote
on that as soon as possible,
that would be [INAUDIBLE].
WILLIAM GREEN: OK, got that?
So final review is either
Wednesday evening or Friday
morning, you have to vote.
And if you come
today, 5:00 to 5:30,
it'll be all about
Kinetic Monte Carlo.
And other times today
are about anything
you want to talk about.
And the homework solution
will be posted shortly,
I think, for the last
homework that was graded.
Anything else?
All right, good luck as
you study and good luck
on the exam.